♪ ♪ ♪
- La Barbade est réputée
pour ses plages, son rhum,
le calypso, la chanteuse
Rihanna, et un passé colonial
douloureux.
"Le parlement colonialiste,
dit-il, présidé par le roi
d'Angleterre, a statué que
les Noirs n'étaient pas
des êtres humains, mais un bien,
une possession".
Voici l'ancienne villa qui
domine toujours une des plus
importantes plantations
de cannes à sucre du pays.
Selon l'historien, 30 000
esclaves africains, hommes,
femmes et enfants, sont morts
dans les champs des plantations
Drax.
"La Reine, dit-
le futur roi, doit s'excuser
à tous les Africains pour
ces crimes contre l'humanité
et réparer les dommages causés
par 200 ans d'esclavage, suivies
par 100 ans de suprématie
blanche et d'apartheid".
Le Prince Charles, qui
participe aux célébrations
marquant la fin du règne royal
à La Barbade, a plutôt souligné
la "résilience extraordinaire
du peuple qui a survécu
aux atrocités épouvantables
de l'esclavage."
Voici celle qui remplace
désormais la Reine Élisabeth II
comme chef d'État de la Barbade.
La nouvelle présidente n'aura
qu'un rôle honorifique,
semblable à celui qui était
le sien quand elle était
gouverneure générale.
Le pouvoir exécutif demeure
concentré dans les mains
de la Première ministre.
Mia Mottley vient d'écrire
une page d'histoire. Elle tenait
à le faire pour donner confiance
aux Barbadiens, leur dire
que tout est possible.
La Première ministre, élue avec
72 % des suffrages il y a trois
ans, a profité de sa popularité
et de l'effervescence
des mouvements antiracistes
pour amener son peuple
vers cette émancipation.
BENOIT PELLETIER,
constitutionnaliste Univ. Ottawa
- Il y a eu ces dernières anné
des mouvements comme Black Lives
matter, qui a suscité un désir
de la part des Barbadiens
de s'émanciper par rapport
à la Couronne brita
(clairon)
- Le constitutionnaliste
ne croit pas que l'exemple
de la Barbade entraînera
d'autres pays à laisser tomber
la reine comme chef d'État.
Mais l'éventuel décès
d'Elizabeth II, qui a 95 ans,
pourrait avoir un effet domino.
- S'il y avait une volonté
du peuple, une volonté
de la population cadadienne
d'abolir la monarchie,
je suis convaincu que
les acteurs politiques
trouveraient le moyen
d'appliquelala procédure
de modification
constitutionnelle pertinente.
♪ ♪ ♪
- La Barbade célèbre
son inpependance en couronnant
une nouvelle reine. Rihanna
devient la première citoyenne
de la nouvelle république
à être honorée. La superstar,
qui a prouvé que tout était
possible, en vendant près de
300 millions d'albums,
est nommée ambassadrice
et héroïne nationale.